Choice Hotels get you more of what you value. Here's a little tune to help you remember. Same drive, different day. Don't you wish you were getting away? Pack your beds and come on through. Texas, Ohio, Alaska, we're up there too. Comfort in. It's calling your name.
Choice Hotels 让您获得更多您所看重的价值。这是一首小曲子，帮您记住这一点。同样的旅程，不同的一天。您难道不想出去走走吗？收拾好行囊，过来看看吧。德克萨斯州、俄亥俄州、阿拉斯加州，我们也在那里。入住舒适酒店，它在呼唤您的名字。
Save on the stay. Oh, and free waffles are yours to claim. Well, I hope you like my little song. Book direct at choiceotails.com. This episode of Speaking of Psychology was recorded on October 1st. Although it is not yet November, the 2020 elections have effectively begun. Election officials are seeing a surge of early and mail-in ballots around the country, and lots of other voters will head to the polls on November 3rd to vote in person.
节省住宿费用。哦，还有免费华夫饼等着您享用。好吧，希望您喜欢我的这首小歌。请直接在 choicehotels.com 预订。本期《心理学谈话》录制于 10 月 1 日。虽然还没到 11 月，但 2020 年大选实际上已经开始了。全国各地的选举官员发现提前投票和邮寄选票的数量激增，还有许多选民将在 11 月 3 日前往投票站进行现场投票。
Many Americans see this as the most consequential election in recent American history. Amid the backdrop of a pandemic, a season of racial unrest, a suddenly open Supreme Court seat and months of natural disasters fueled by climate change. What will shape voters' decisions this year? What are the psychological forces at play when people decide to vote and whom to vote for? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
许多美国人认为这是美国近代史上最重要的一次选举。背景是全球大流行、种族动荡时期、最高法院席位突然空缺，以及气候变化引发的数月自然灾害。今年是什么在影响选民的决定？当人们决定投票以及投给谁时，背后有哪些心理力量在起作用？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探索心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。
Our guest today is Dr. John Krosnick, a social psychologist who directs the political, political psychology research group at Stanford University. He has spent 30 years studying Americans' political attitudes, what drives them to turn out for elections, and how their political attitudes shape their voting choices. In recent years, he's had a particular interest in climate change attitudes, which Americans say is one of the most critical issues we are facing. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, Dr. Krosnick. Thank you so much for having me. It's the pleasure to be here. Right now, polls are showing Joe Biden ahead of Donald Trump in many battleground states. You've done research on polling and survey methodology. How seriously should voters take these polls right now?
我们今天的嘉宾是约翰·克罗斯尼克博士，他是一位社会心理学家，负责斯坦福大学政治心理学研究小组。他花了 30 年时间研究美国人的政治态度、是什么促使他们参加选举，以及他们的政治态度如何塑造他们的投票选择。近年来，他特别关注气候变化态度，美国人称这是我们面临的最关键问题之一。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，克罗斯尼克博士。非常感谢您的邀请。很高兴来到这里。目前，民意调查显示乔·拜登在许多摇摆州领先于唐纳德·特朗普。您在民意调查和调查方法方面做过研究。选民现在应该多认真地看待这些民调？
Well, it's a wonderful question, and it's one that I'm very glad that the country is interested in. Unfortunately, a memory many people have about the polls is that in 2016, many people went to bed the night before the election believing that from the poll aggregators 538.com, the upshot at the New York Times, and others, that Hillary Clinton had a probability of winning that election somewhere between the high 60s and the 90s. And when, in fact, she didn't win, of course, it was a historic moment for the country, but it was also an important moment for social science because the sense in which the polls are broken and perhaps hopelessly broken was certainly an appealing interpretation to many
嗯，这是一个非常好的问题，我也很高兴全国人民都对此感兴趣。不幸的是，许多人对民调的记忆是 2016 年，当时许多人在选举前一天晚上睡觉时，根据民调汇总机构 538.com、《纽约时报》的“上策”栏目以及其他机构的预测，认为希拉里·克林顿赢得选举的概率在 60% 到 90% 之间。而事实上，她并没有获胜，这当然是美国历史上的一个重要时刻，但对社会科学来说也是一个重要时刻，因为民调已经崩溃，甚至可能无可救药地崩溃，这种感觉对许多人来说确实是一种很有吸引力的解释。
people. But I'm happy to say that that is wrong. that the polls, it's important to differentiate two kinds of surveys, the scientific ones and the not-so-scientific ones. Scientific surveys involve truly random samples of people. And that methodology done with what's called random digit dialing, where we generate random numbers to call all possible landlines and cell phones with known probabilities, that method has produced startlingly accurate pre-election predictions for, decades. And in fact, that method worked beautifully in 2016. The polls done during the last week before the election, either national polls or state polls, predicted the outcomes for President Trump and for Secretary Clinton with about one percentage point of error, just about exactly
但我很高兴地说，那是错误的。重要的是要区分两种调查：科学的调查和不那么科学的调查。科学调查涉及真正随机的人群样本。这种使用所谓“随机数字拨号”的方法，即我们生成随机号码来拨打所有可能的固定电话和手机，并具有已知的概率，这种方法几十年来一直产生惊人准确的选前预测。事实上，这种方法在 2016 年运作得非常完美。选举前最后一周进行的民调，无论是全国民调还是州民调，对特朗普总统和克林顿国务卿的选举结果预测误差仅在 1 个百分点左右，几乎完全正确。
right. The unfortunate fact is that there were many, many more non-scientific polls that involved not random samples, and instead samples of people who either volunteer to do surveys regularly for money or samples of people who were scooped up by a method called river sampling. And so these are people who are doing something on the internet and, for example, want to read a newspaper article and a box pops up that says, before you can read the article, you need to answer this question, who you're going to vote for on Tuesday. There's nothing scientific about those samples. There's nothing random about those samples. Unfortunately, companies are selling those samples as if they are scientific, and those are the samples that were way off with errors as big as 16 percentage
不幸的事实是，还有许多非科学的民调，它们不涉及随机样本，而是涉及那些为了钱定期自愿参加调查的人，或者是通过一种叫“河流抽样”的方法收集的人。这些人正在互联网上做某事，例如想阅读一篇报纸文章，然后弹出一个框说，在阅读文章之前，您需要回答这个问题：您周二打算投给谁？这些样本没有任何科学性可言。这些样本没有任何随机性。不幸的是，一些公司正在把这些样本当作科学样本来出售，而这些样本的误差高达 16 个百分点，考虑到其背后没有任何科学依据，这也就不足为奇了。
points off, not surprising given that there was no science behind it. So the answer is that happily, I think many news organizations learned that lesson, and for many of us in 2020, we are watching the polls more often the ones getting high visibility, not always, but the ones getting high visibility so far are the scientific random sample polls. And unfortunately, you know, for your listeners, the challenge is when you see a poll, how can you decide whether it's one that you should trust or not? And of course, I know the survey organizations. And so when I see when I know what methods they use, and so I can tell, and I would like it if the news media would tell everybody when they report on a survey, whether it's a truly random sample or not. And if you care,
所以答案是，令人高兴的是，我认为许多新闻机构吸取了教训。对于我们许多人来说，在 2020 年，我们更频繁地关注民调，那些获得高曝光度的民调——并非总是如此，但到目前为止获得高曝光度的民调——都是科学的随机样本民调。不幸的是，对于您的听众来说，挑战在于当您看到一个民调时，如何判断它是否值得信任？当然，我了解这些调查机构。所以当我看到并知道他们使用什么方法时，我就能分辨出来。我希望新闻媒体在报道调查时能告诉大家，这是否是一个真正的随机样本。如果您关心的话，
take a minute and click some links to follow through to find a methodology right up. And if you find the description is a random digit dial by telephone, by human interviewers to landlines and cell phones, that's the critical factor. And so the good news is by careful sampling, we can still learn. And I hope before this election that there will be not only lots of scientific national polls, but lots of scientific state polls so that we all have a good sense of what to expect. when the votes are counted. And as I say, there is a track record that goes back many decades showing we should have strong expectations based on scientific polls. So it's not necessarily a brand or a name that the public should be looking for, although that may be part of it, like whether you look at a Gallup poll or National
花一分钟点击一些链接，查看方法论说明。如果您发现描述是“由人工访谈员通过电话对固定电话和手机进行随机数字拨号”，这就是关键因素。好消息是，通过仔细的抽样，我们仍然可以了解情况。我希望在这次选举之前，不仅会有大量的全国性科学民调，还会有大量的州级科学民调，这样我们大家在计票时都能对结果有很好的预判。正如我所说，几十年的记录表明，我们应该基于科学民调有很强的预期。所以公众不一定非要盯着某个品牌或名字，尽管这可能是一部分，比如您看盖洛普民调或芝加哥大学的国家民意研究中心，但真正受过教育的消费者应该关注方法论。这就是诀窍。
Opinion Research Center out of the University of Chicago, for example, but that really educated consumers should be looking at the methodology. That's the trick. Yeah. And luckily, there's only a little bit of the, the methodology to look for. This pretty much differentiates the pros from not. Random sampling, random digit dial, RDD, it's called telephone, human interviewers, landline cell phones. And I can tell you that, you know, there are certain organizations. You mentioned Gallup. Gallup stopped doing pre-election polls. I'm not aware that they're doing them now. But the Pew Research Center is doing them. They're very reliable. ABC News is another example of a very reliable organization.
是的。幸运的是，需要关注的方法论只有一点点。这基本上区分了专业人士和非专业人士。随机抽样、随机数字拨号（RDD）、电话、人工访谈员、固定电话和手机。我可以告诉您，有一些机构。您提到了盖洛普。盖洛普停止了选前民调。我不确定他们现在是否在做。但皮尤研究中心正在做。他们非常可靠。美国广播公司新闻部是另一个非常可靠的机构的例子。
And there are others as well. Kwynipiac University is another one that partners, I think, maybe with the Washington Post. That's another one using random digital. And there are others as well. You published a review study called Why Do People Vote? And one thing you found is that door-to-door canvassing is one of the most effective ways to increase voter turnout, whereas phone calls seem to make no difference. Can you talk about that research and how that might be playing out this year?
还有其他一些机构。昆尼皮亚克大学是另一个合作伙伴，我想可能与《华盛顿邮报》合作。这也是另一个使用随机数字拨号的机构。还有其他一些。您发表了一项名为《人们为什么投票？》的综述研究。您发现的一件事是，挨家挨户的拉票是提高选民投票率最有效的方法之一，而电话似乎没有任何区别。您能谈谈这项研究以及它今年可能如何发挥作用吗？
Yes, really many people think of Don Green, who is a political scientist at Columbia University, as a really important contributor to our understanding of voter mobilization. Because for many decades in America, it's been big business at the time of elections for candidates to pay for television advertising, to pay for radio advertising, to mail out postcards and letters to voters in the hopes of influencing their behavior. And yet, up until Don started to study all of this, we had very little evidence. And Don himself was one of the first people to test the impact of television advertising of candidates and to show really tiny effects of ads that dissipate so quickly they can't possibly influence Election Day.
是的，确实很多人认为哥伦比亚大学的政治学家唐·格林是我们理解选民动员的重要贡献者。因为几十年来，在美国，候选人为电视广告付费、为广播广告付费、向选民邮寄明信片和信件以期影响他们的行为，这在大选时是一项大生意。然而，在唐开始研究这一切之前，我们几乎没有什么证据。唐本人是第一批测试候选人电视广告影响的人之一，他证明了广告的效果非常微小，而且消散得如此之快，以至于它们不可能影响选举日。
And so in a sense, his message was tremendous amounts of money are being spent on ads that have no real measurable impact. and others as well, Lynn Vavrick at UCLA is another one who has done some work in this area and showed the same thing. And it's really very difficult to find any evidence that television advertising, which is quite expensive for candidates, has any consequences. So Don then turned to this question of voter mobilization. And the logic really comes from the following, that for a long time, candidates thought that whether you are going to vote or not is pretty much a fixed attribute of you and has nothing. to do with them. And that you're, so either you're a voter or you're not. And the real question is, can they convert you to vote for them instead of for their
所以从某种意义上说，他的信息是：大量的金钱被花在了没有真正可衡量影响的广告上。其他人也是如此，加州大学洛杉矶分校的琳恩·瓦夫里克也在这方面做了一些工作，并显示了同样的结果。确实很难找到任何证据表明对候选人来说相当昂贵的电视广告有任何后果。所以唐随后转向了选民动员的问题。逻辑实际上来自以下几点：长期以来，候选人认为您是否投票很大程度上是您的固定属性，与他们无关。所以要么您是选民，要么您不是。真正的问题是，他们能否让您转而投给他们而不是他们的对手？
opponent? And in recent years, the professionals working in this area became much more enlightened by realizing that actually it's quite hard to convince people to move from one side to the other in terms of candidates. But it is much easier to activate a person who probably. will vote but might not vote into actually voting. So imagine that you have kind of a 70% background probability of voting that giving you a bit of a nudge can make a significant difference. And if before I give you that nudge, I know that if I can nudge you into voting, you'll vote for me.
近年来，在这一领域工作的专业人士变得更加开明，他们意识到实际上很难说服人们在候选人方面从一边倒向另一边。但激活一个可能投票但可能不会投票的人去实际投票要容易得多。所以想象一下，您有 70% 的投票背景概率，给我一点推动力可能会产生重大影响。如果在我给您那个推动力之前，我知道如果我能推动您去投票，您就会投给我。
Then that's a good thing. And so the Obama campaign is widely credited in 2008 with really paying attention to Don's research and realizing that it made sense on a scientific and an empirical basis to deploy resources to try to figure out who would vote for Obama if they vote and to figure out who to nudge to have the most impact on them. And what Don's field experiments showed was that mailing out postcards to people has very little, if any, effect. Making phone calls to people has very little, if any, effect. But having the right conversation on the doorstep actually produced quite measurable effects, increasing turnout.
那是一件好事。因此，奥巴马竞选团队在 2008 年被广泛认为真正关注了唐的研究，并意识到在科学和经验的基础上配置资源来弄清楚谁会在投票时投给奥巴马，以及弄清楚推动谁能产生最大的影响，这是有道理的。唐的实地实验表明，给人们邮寄明信片几乎没有什么效果，如果有的话。给人们打电话几乎没有什么效果，如果有的话。但在门口进行正确的对话实际上产生了相当可衡量的效果，提高了投票率。
And so for psychologists, we ask the question, why? What is it that happens during that face-to-face conversation that causes an increase in turnout? And in fact, we've known for quite a while from Tony Greenwald, who's at the University of Washington and his research, where way ahead of the curve, he realized that it was possible during a conversation like that with a person to simply ask one question on election day, are you going to vote? And asking that question is enough of a nudge to actually alter behavior.
所以对于心理学家来说，我们问的问题是，为什么？在那次面对面的谈话中发生了什么导致了投票率的增加？事实上，我们从华盛顿大学的托尼·格林沃尔德及其研究中已经知道了一段时间，他走在时代前沿，他意识到在与人进行那样的谈话时，可以在选举日简单地问一个问题：您打算投票吗？问那个问题足以作为一个推动力来实际改变行为。
And I'll tell you about the studies that he did. What he did was to randomly assign households that were listed in the state of Washington official government records as being registered to vote. He had undergraduates at the University of Washington, I think, make phone calls to those randomly selected households for which he could get phone numbers. And each household was randomly assigned to get one of the following two quick conversations. Hi, I'm an undergraduate at the University of Washington doing a survey in the psychology department. It's just one question today. Are you going to vote in the election on Tuesday or who do you think is going to win the Seattle Seahawks football game on Sunday? And so each person's randomly assigned either to get that vote question or to get the football question.
我会告诉您他所做的研究。他所做的是随机分配那些在华盛顿州官方政府记录中登记投票的家庭。我想他让华盛顿大学的本科生给那些他能获得电话号码的随机选择的家庭打电话。每个家庭被随机分配进行以下两段简短对话中的一段。您好，我是华盛顿大学心理学系的本科生，正在进行一项调查。今天只有一个问题。您打算在周二的选举中投票吗？或者您认为谁会赢得周日的西雅图海鹰队橄榄球比赛？所以每个人都被随机分配要么回答那个投票问题，要么回答那个橄榄球问题。
And the evidence that Tony provided from a series of studies is that simply asking that question, are you going to vote, actually increases turnout because there are people who kind of lean in the direction of voting. And when they hear themselves say, yeah, I'm going to vote, it actually changes their self-concept and creates a little bit more crystallization of a behavioral intention. And so that same logic, I think, makes sense and applies on doorsteps. And so that turns out to be a technique that was used in 2008 and in subsequent elections. And as you know, 2016 allowed it to happen. 2020 is not so much. The idea of going around and knocking on doors and talking face to face with people is unimaginable for most. And so that's one of them, so many things that makes this a remarkably different delection from what we've been used to.
托尼从一系列研究中提供的证据是，简单地问“您打算投票吗”这个问题，实际上增加了投票率，因为有些人倾向于投票。当他们听到自己说“是的，我要去投票”时，它实际上改变了他们的自我概念，并使行为意图更加具体化。所以我认为同样的逻辑在门口也是合理的，也是适用的。事实证明，这是一种在 2008 年和随后的选举中使用的技术。如您所知，2016 年允许它发生。2020 年则不然。到处敲门并与人面对面交谈的想法对大多数人来说是不可想象的。所以这是让这次选举与我们习惯的选举截然不同的众多事情之一。
And I think many people who want to make a difference are volunteering to make phone calls. And it may make the phone callers feel better to make the phone calls. But at least Don's evidence is that not seeing somebody, not talking to somebody who you can connect with on the doorstep and answering that question freely, you know, at least in his studies, didn't work. but we should remember in Tony Greenwald's studies, it did work to call people on the phone and simply ask that question. So maybe we shouldn't completely abandon that notion in 2020. Given that the research shows that advertising and postcards and some of these phone calls are not very effective, why do campaigns continue to spend money on them? Such a wonderful question.
我认为许多想有所作为的人正在志愿打电话。打电话可能会让打电话的人感觉更好。但至少唐的证据是，看不到某人，不与您可以在门口联系并自由回答那个问题的人交谈，至少在他的研究中，并没有奏效。但我们应该记住，在托尼·格林沃尔德的研究中，打电话给人们并简单地问那个问题确实奏效了。所以也许我们不应该在 2020 年完全放弃这个概念。鉴于研究表明广告、明信片和其中一些电话效果不佳，为什么竞选团队继续在上面花钱？真是个好问题。
Seems logical to me. I'm sorry to tell you there are so many instances in which I am amazed that business spends money in ways that don't work, that government does things that the public doesn't want it to do. And one potential answer to your question is that they simply aren't aware of the research. If the research is being done, it's being published in academic journals, it's certainly known. in some circles, but maybe not in their circles. I'll tell you a story, though, that gave me a little bit of insight in general into this. I was lucky to be able to collaborate with some folks at the University of Chicago at their public policy school in sponsoring a series of workshops, wonderful workshops, where they brought together political psychologists, political
对我来说似乎合乎逻辑。很抱歉告诉您，有太多例子让我惊讶，企业以无效的方式花钱，政府做公众不希望它做的事情。对您问题的潜在回答是，他们根本不知道这项研究。如果研究正在进行，它发表在学术期刊上，在某些圈子里肯定是已知的，但可能不在他们的圈子里。不过，我会给您讲一个让我对这一点有了总体了解的故事。我很幸运能与芝加哥大学公共政策学院的一些人合作，赞助了一系列研讨会，非常棒的研讨会，他们将政治心理学家、政治科学家与竞选专业人士聚集在一起。当我们筹备这个活动时，我们在学术界确实认为我们有很多东西要学。我们想了解的是，那些职业生涯取决于他们对选民思维洞察力的专业人士，如何能告诉我们——说实话，我们是学者，我们坐在办公桌前，我们为彼此写论文，我们的职业生涯并不取决于我们科学评估的准确性。我们确信，我们能从他们那里学到很多东西，这将增强我们的学术研究、文献以及对选民和选举的理解。令我们惊讶的是，当我们把这些人聚在一起时，我们基本上说的是，来芝加哥吧，我们会告诉你们我们学者认为我们知道什么，然后你们告诉我们我们哪里错了，你们知道什么。所以当我们聚在一起进行演讲时，专业人士说，非常感谢。我们真的很感谢所有这些见解。我们不是这样想的。我们根本不知道有这样的文献。这真的很有帮助。坦率地说，我们自己没有任何理论。
scientists, together with campaign professionals. And when we set this up, we thought, really, on the academic side that we had a lot to learn in this situation. And what we wanted to learn was how professionals whose careers live and die based upon their insights into how voters think could tell us who, let's face it, we're academics, we sit at our desks, we write papers for each other, our careers don't live and die on the accuracy of our scientific assessments. We thought for sure, you know, there would be a lot that we could learn from them and that would enhance our scholarship and our literatures and our understanding of voters and elections. And what we were amazed to learn was when we brought these folks together and we essentially
我们说，好吧，你们怎么可能没有理论？我的意思是，你们怎么知道该做什么？他们说，好吧，我们只是做我们一直做的事情。有一些制作特定类型广告的传统，我们只是继续这样做。因为我们看不到任何替代方案。所以当我们问他们时，例如，当您制作电视广告时，您会像科学家那样测试它以查看它产生的影响吗？哦，不，我们绝对不这样做。您知道，为什么不呢？嗯，因为我们没有时间，也没有钱。所以当我们学者评估广告的影响时，我们发现
what we said was, you know, come to Chicago, we'll tell you what we, academics think we know, and then you tell us how we're wrong and what you know. And so when we got together and made the presentations, the professional said, thank you so much. We really appreciate all of this insight. And we don't think this way. We had no idea that there was such literature. This is really helpful. And frankly, we have no theories of our own.
大多数都没有影响。少数有预期的影响，有些实际上适得其反。所以如果我是候选人，我正在为这些广告付费，我肯定会要求对它们进行测试，特别是考虑到测试并不那么昂贵。当然，这正是心理学家的看家本领。但这并不是常规做法。在许多领域，人们在做决定时更多地基于直觉，而不是数据，尽管实际上有可靠且可用的科学数据。有没有一种特定类型的广告是有效的？嗯，您问得很有趣。如您所知，过去 30 年来，政治广告一直对所谓的负面或攻击性广告感兴趣。其理念是不要花时间宣传您的候选人，而要花时间攻击您的对手并试图抹黑那个人。在心理学文献中，这确实有一个逻辑。它被称为“消极效应”。
And we said, well, how can you not have theory? I mean, how do you know what to do? And they said, well, we just do what we always did. That there are traditions and making ads of certain types, and we just keep right on doing it. Because we don't see any alternatives. And so when we ask them, for example, when you make a television ad, do you test it to see the impact that it has, the way a scientist would. Oh, no, definitely we don't do that. You know, why not? Well, because we don't have time and we don't have money. And so when we academics evaluate the impact of ads, what we find
总的来说，来自许多不同类型研究的观点是，我可以告诉您关于一个人的五件好事，但如果我告诉您关于那个人的这一件坏事，它会不成比例地影响您对那个人的印象。所以您可能会认为专注于抹黑是有道理的。问题在于，这些攻击性广告中有太多需要编造一些被夸大得令人恐惧的故事，并且以我所说的“鲨鱼鳍音乐”、黑暗图像和阴森的声音呈现，我想我们大家都对它们感到厌倦了。
is most of them have no impact. A few of them have impact in the intended way, and some of them actually backfire. And so if I were a candidate and I were paying for those ads, I would certainly ask that they be tested, especially because testing isn't all that expensive. And it's, of course, exactly the bread and butter for psychologists. But it's just not something that's routinely done. That in many fields, you know, people operate in making decisions based more on instinct, I think, than on data when there actually are scientific data that are reliable and available for them. Is there a particular type of ad that is effective? Well, you know, interesting you should ask. We actually, as you know, there has been an attraction
例如威利·霍顿的广告。那个，正是，众多广告中的一个。所以美国人对广告充耳不闻是一个问题。因此，我们在斯坦福大学的小组实际上已经开始寻求一种替代方案，即探索尊重的、信息性的、教育性的广告。我的意思是，例如，我们研究了各个政党的经济记录。所以您可以想象，如果您要画一张图表，底部是 1940 年至今的年份，左侧是美国的失业率。我们观察了那段时间内民主党总统和共和党总统执政期间失业率的起伏模式。我们发现了一个显著的模式，即在一个政党执政下，失业率几乎总是下降，而在另一个政党执政下，失业率几乎总是上升。人们认为美国人的投票受到经济的重大影响，特别是受到失业率的影响。所以我们做了一个非常简单的实验，我们让一些人看了一个信息性广告，向他们展示了这个图表并向他们解释。治疗组看到了失业广告。
in political advertising over the last 30 years to what are called negative or attack ads. The idea is don't spend time promoting your candidate, spend time attacking your opponent and trying to discredit that person. And there actually is a logic in psychology in our literature for that. It's called negativity effects.
对照组则看到了一个与此无关的消费品广告。我们发现，观看该广告在统计学上显著改善了对那个在失业率下降期间执政的政党的态度，增加了对该政党不仅能管理失业而且能管理经济的能力的信心，增加了对该政党的认同感，更多人称自己为该政党的成员，而且人们在观看广告后确实表示他们更有可能投票给该政党的候选人。所以这是一个非常不同类型的广告的例子，我认为它以尊重的态度为人们提供了事实信息。
And in general, the notion from lots of different types of research is that I can tell you five good things about a person, but if I tell you one bad thing about that person, It influences your impression of the person disproportionately. And so you might imagine that it makes sense to focus attention on discrediting. The problem is that so many of these attack ads require kind of making up stories that are sort of puffed up to be scary and, you know, are presented with what I call shark fin music and dark images and a voice and ominous sounding voice that I think we've all gotten pretty. tired of them.
显然您现在知道，在我们生活的世界里，对于什么是事实存在很多不确定性，因为失业率是由美国人口普查局测量的，并且在所有这些总统任期内都有记录，人口普查局当然是在这些总统任期的批准下运作的，因此将其作为事实正确的信息呈现是合理的。所以通过在广告中向人们呈现这些信息，我们看到人们对各政党的经济记录有了更好的了解。事实上，这显著地塑造了他们的态度和投票意图。所以我猜我会说这是一个有效的例子。竞选团队显然不知道这一点。就是这样。让我们换个话题。
The Willie Horton ad, for example. That one, exactly, one of many. And so the sense in which Americans tune out the ads is one issue. And so our group at Stanford has actually started to pursue an alternative, which is to explore respectful informational educational ads. And what I mean by that is that, for example, we have looked at. at the economic track records of various political parties. And so you can imagine that if you were to picture a graph that along the bottom has years from 1940 to the present, and then over on the left-hand
我想谈谈恐惧对选民的影响。现在，一个竞选团队，我想我应该说是特朗普竞选团队，正试图激励人们做一些事情，比如为了保护郊区的生活方式而投票，为了结束他们所说的某些城市中的左翼暴力，甚至因为系统被操纵而投票两次。民主党人则在说，特朗普再执政四年将导致《平价医疗法案》的终结、《罗诉韦德案》的终结、持续的动荡。所以这两个政党和竞选团队都在推行恐惧信息。作为激励人们投票和投给他们的人的动力，这些信息有多大的说服力？好问题。所以您当然准确地描述了这些天正在发生的事情。我认为有两种方式来思考您所描述的信息。
side is the unemployment rate in America. We looked at the patterns of unemployment up and down over that time period under Democratic presidents and Republican presidents. And what we found, was a remarkable pattern, whereby under one party, unemployment almost always has gone down, and under the other party, unemployment has almost always gone up. And Americans are thought to be very importantly influenced in their voting by economics, and they're thought to be influenced by unemployment in particular. And so we did a very simple experiment where we exposed some people to an informational ad that showed them this graph and explained it to them. And the treatment group saw the unemployment ad.
所以，您可能会说，一条信息说——事实上，乔·拜登前几天在辩论中确实说过，特朗普总统正寻求推翻所有的奥巴马医改，并且在本届总统任期结束前任命一位新的最高法院大法官很可能会提供所需的选票来实现这一目标。所以乔·拜登这样说，说“嘿，美国，听着，只要记住，如果这位法官被任命，最高法院很可能会宣布奥巴马医改违宪，整个计划将被取消”。您可以想象将其描绘成旨在引起恐惧的信息，但您也可以认为这同一条信息是一条教育信息，对吧？许多人，我想包括特朗普总统在内，会说，是的，那完全正确。我确实想推翻奥巴马医改，我想依靠最高法院来做到这一点。增加最高法院中倾向于共和党的大法官人数将增强我实现这一目标的能力。所以我认为总统实际上不会不同意这一点。乔·拜登提到这一点，您可以说，这是教育选民他们所面临的政策选择的有益一步。然而，正如您所说，对于那些现在通过奥巴马医改获得医疗保健并认为他们从一个他们可能认为是负担得起的计划中受益的人来说，他们可能有严重的既往病史，他们可能担心他们对既往病史的承保会消失，
The control group instead saw an ad for some consumer product that was unrelated. And what we found was seeing the ad improved that, you know, seeing that one ad statistically significantly improved attitudes toward the party that presided over reductions in unemployment, increased confidence in that party's ability not only to manage unemployment but to manage the economy, increased identification with that party, more people called themselves members of that party, and people actually said they were more likely to vote for candidates from that party after seeing the ad. And so this is an example of a very different kind of ad that I think it provides respectfully for people factual information.
对他们来说，这是一种引起恐惧的信息。这很可怕。我们在心理学中几十年来一直知道，恐惧可以在一定程度上成为一种动力，恐惧可以激活人们去关注、去更好地学习并更有动力去采取行动。但如果您没有可用的策略来有效地感到您能够减少这种恐惧并减少不良结果发生的可能性，那么恐惧就没有帮助。我认为美国现在的问题是，正如许多人所说，我们正处于历史上前所未有的时刻，美国总统说：“我不认为我可以信任投票过程。”
And obviously you now know that in the world we live in, there's so much uncertain to me at what actually is factual or not that presenting this information because the unemployment rate is measured by the U.S. Census Bureau and it's been measured and is on the record under all of those presidents that the Census Bureau, of course, was operating under the approval of those presidencies, that it's reasonable to present that as factually correct information. And so by presenting that information to people in an ad, what we saw was people became better informed about the economic track records of the parties. And that, in fact, shaped their attitudes and their voting intentions strikingly. So I guess I would say that's an example of something that works. Campaigns obviously don't know that. We don't. That's it. Let's change gears for a minute.
当这种信息来自除了总统之外的民选官员时，他们负责投票，负责管理邮寄选票及时计票的过程，以一种我们通常认为理所当然的方式——邮政服务与此无关。当然，他们做他们的工作，没什么可担心的。现在美国人被告知，涉及邮寄选票的投递确实有一些值得担心的事情，投票过程本身有这么多方面，我认为在目前美国人的心目中，导致了他们实际上无法解决这个问题的缺乏信心。
I want to talk about the influence of fear on voters. Now, one campaign, I guess I should say it's the Trump campaign, is trying to motivate people to do things like vote in order to preserve the suburban way of life, to end what they say is left-wing violence in some cities, maybe even to vote twice because the system is rigged. The Democrats are saying things like another four years for Trump will lead to the end of the Affordable Care Act, Roe versus Wade, continued unrest. So both of these parties and campaigns are pushing messages of fear. How compelling are such messages as a motivator to get people to vote and to vote for their guy? Great question. So you've, of course, accurately described what's happening these days. And I think there are two ways to think about the messages that you have described.
换句话说，如果他们希望奥巴马医改继续运作，他们能做什么？嗯，答案是您可以投票，除非这清楚吗？您可以投票吗？您的选票真的会被计入吗？我认为许多美国人说“我现在对这一点没有两年前、四年前或八年前那样的信心”是合理的。所以不幸的是，手头的解决方案，或者可能被提议作为恐惧的解决方案，那就是投票。如果您想确保总统继续担任总统，请投票。如果您想确保总统下台，请投票。
So, you know, you might say that a message saying, in fact, Joe Biden did say the other night during the debate that President Trump is seeking to overturn all of Obamacare and that the appointment of a new Supreme Court justice before the end of this term for the president could well provide the needed votes in order to accomplish that. And so for Joe Biden to say that, to say, hey, America, listen, just bear in mind if this justice gets appointed, most likely the Supreme Court will declare, Obamacare unconstitutional and the entire program will be eliminated. You can imagine portraying that as a message meant to induce fear, but you can also think of that very same message as an
问题是即使是这样，思考那个行动也会引起这种更大的恐惧和不确定感。所以，我们谈论这次选举可能是美国很长一段时间以来投票率最高的选举。然而，也有可能如果这种情况再持续一个月，人们可能会变得沮丧、失去活力并感到无能为力。对于心理学界的人来说，您可能还记得多年前在实验室研究中证明的“习得性无助”的概念。如果您把动物放在一个它们会受到电击的情况下，它们学会了无法避免，它们只是坐在角落里承受，因为它们失去了控制和摆脱痛苦的感觉。而且，习得性无助在一些美国人身上产生作用并从而破坏他们的投票率，这是一种非常真实的可能性。
educational message, right, that many people, I think, including President Trump, would say, yes, that's exactly right. I do want to overturn Obamacare, and I want to rely on the Supreme Court to do that. And increasing the number of Republican-leaning justices on the Supreme Court will enhance my ability to accomplish that. So I think the president actually wouldn't disagree with any of that. And the fact that Joe Biden mentioned it, you could say, is a helpful step in educating voters about the policy choices that they face. And yet, as you say, for people who have health care right now through Obamacare and who feel that they have benefited from a program that they might consider affordable, they might have serious pre-execis. conditions, they might be worried that their coverage for pre-existing conditions would disappear,
目前看来，似乎很少有选民不知道他们支持哪位总统候选人。现在，我看到目前有 3% 到 11% 的人未决定。这是一个异常低的未决定人数吗？您认为在这一点上改变人们的想法有多困难？嗯，您准确地描述了询问人们“您是否已经决定”的调查结果。我会让您感到惊讶的是，我认为这不是调查中应该问的明智问题。因为如果有人说“是的，我已经下定决心了”。然后他们发现乔·拜登或唐纳德·特朗普在家中被抓到，手里拿着一把刀，刺向他们刚刚谋杀的人的胸口，
that for them, it is a fear-inducing message. It is scary. And what we've known for many decades in psychology is that fear can be a motivator up to a point, that fear can activate people to pay attention and to learn better and to be more motivated to take action. But fear is not helpful if you don't have a strategy available to you to effectively feel that you're able to reduce that fear and reduce the likelihood of the undesirable outcome happening. And the problem I think right now for America is that, as so many people are saying, we're in this unprecedented moment in history when the President of the United States has said, I don't think I can trust the voting process.
那么，人们当然会重新考虑他们的决定。所以当有人说“我已经下定决心了”时，他们真正想说的是，“我无法想象从现在到选举日之间我会得到什么信息会导致我改变目前的倾向”。所以这里真正的问题是，他们是在现实地想象吗？我猜答案是大多数人不能，因为我们不可能知道《纽约时报》上周会公布唐纳德·特朗普的纳税申报表。我们无法知道从现在到选举日之间无疑会发生的各种其他事情。所以我们真正想做的是告诉人们，好吧，您还不知道这一点，但这些是会从现在到选举日之间发生的事情。
And when that message comes from elected officials who are, in addition to the president, who are charged with voting, who are charged with managing the process of mail-in ballots being counted in a timely fashion, in a way that normally we would take for granted the postal service is kind of irrelevant to this. Of course, they do their job and there's nothing to worry about. Now Americans have been told there is something to worry about involving simply the delivery of those mail. in ballots, that there are so many aspects of the voting process itself that contributes, I think, in the minds of Americans at the moment to a lack of confidence that they can actually solve this problem.
例如，将会有一场辩论。在辩论期间，候选人之间会有很多大喊大叫。他们会互相打断等等。那场辩论的收视率不是特别高，但新闻报道非常多。这只是我认为大多数人会说“我们以前从未在总统辩论中见过这种水平”的事情的一个例子。所以人们猜测辩论是否会改变我的想法？嗯，他们认为辩论是我们习惯的那种正常辩论。所以鉴于人们无法知道所有将要展开的事件，我们真的不能指望他们猜测他们是否会改变主意。
In other words, if they want Obamacare to stay in action, you know, what can they do? Well, you know, the answer is you can vote, except is it clear? Can you vote? Is your vote actually going to get counted? I think it's reasonable for many Americans to say, I don't have the confidence in that now that I had two years ago or four years ago or eight years ago. And so unfortunately, the solution at hand or what might be proposed as a solution for fear, that is vote. If you want to make sure the president stays the president, vote. If you want to make sure the president's out, vote.
如果您允许我，这是一个提到心理学中其他里程碑式研究的绝佳时刻，特别是 70 年代弗吉尼亚大学的蒂姆·威尔逊和密歇根大学的迪克·尼斯贝特所做的研究。汇集了心理学中大量的文献，表明当您问人们这样的问题时——您是如何做决定的？您为什么决定买这辆车而不是那辆车？您为什么嫁给这个人而不是别人？总的来说，我们无法充分获取大脑的运作方式，以至于无法准确描述这些问题的答案。事实上，相反，我们编造故事。我们说，嗯，为什么有人会嫁给那样的人？我想这是一个很好的理由。所以在这个案例中，要求人们猜测他们甚至无法预料的信息是否会改变他们的想法，是在问他们我所说的“尼斯贝特-威尔逊式”的内省问题，我们实际上并没有准备好回答。所以请原谅我说，您问题的前提完全正确。
And the problem is even that, thinking about that action induces this greater sense of fear and uncertainty. And so, you know, the potential, we've talked about this election as one that may have the highest levels of turnout that we've seen in America in a long time. And yet, you know, it's also possible that if this keeps up for another month, that people may become depressed and inactivated and to feel incapable. And for people in psychology, you might remember the notion of learned helplessness that was demonstrated years ago in laboratory studies. if you put an animal in a situation where they get an electric shock and they learn that they can't avoid it, they just kind of sit down in the corner and take it because they've lost their sense of being able to control and get out of the pain. And, you know, there is a very real possibility that learned helplessness may kick in with some Americans and thereby undermine their turnout.
问题在于，仅仅是思考那种行动就会引发更强烈的恐惧和不确定感。所以，你知道，我们谈论过这次选举，它可能是美国很长一段时间以来投票率最高的一次。然而，如果这种情况再持续一个月，人们可能会变得沮丧、消极，并感到无能为力。对于心理学界的人来说，你可能还记得多年前在实验室研究中证明的“习得性无助”概念。如果你把一只动物放在一个会受到电击的环境中，而它学会了无法避免这种电击，它最终只会坐在角落里默默承受，因为它失去了控制局面和摆脱痛苦的能力。你知道，习得性无助在一些美国人身上确实有可能发生，从而削弱他们的投票意愿。
It would seem at this point that there are very few, voters who don't know which of the two presidential candidates they support. Now, I've seen between 3% and 11% undecided right now. Is this an unusually low number of undecideds? And how difficult is it to change people's minds at this point, do you think? Well, you are accurately describing results of surveys that ask people, have you decided or not? And I'm going to surprise you by telling you, I don't think that's a sensible question to ask in a survey. Because if somebody says, yep, I've made up my mind. And then they find out that, you know, that there's some news that Joe Biden or Donald Trump is caught at home with a knife in the chest of someone who they've just murdered,
目前看来，似乎很少有选民不知道自己支持哪位总统候选人。现在，我看到的未决定选民比例在3%到11%之间。这是一个异常低的未决定比例吗？你认为在现阶段改变人们的想法有多难？嗯，你准确地描述了那些询问人们“你是否已经决定”的调查结果。但我会让你感到惊讶的是，我认为在调查中问这个问题并不明智。因为如果有人说，“是的，我已经决定了”，然后他们发现，比如，乔·拜登或唐纳德·特朗普在家里被发现手里拿着刀，刺向了他们刚刚谋杀的人的胸口，
then, of course, people are going to rethink their decision. And so when somebody says, I've made up my mind, what they're really saying is, I can't imagine information. that I would get between now and election day that would lead me to change the way I'm leaning at the moment. So the real issue here is, are they imagining realistically? And my guess is the answer is most of us can't be because we could not have known that the New York Times last week would publish Donald Trump's tax returns. And we cannot know various other things that are undoubtedly going to happen between now and election day. So what we would really like to do is to tell people well, okay, you don't know this yet, but these are the kinds of things that are going to happen between now and election day.
那么，人们当然会重新考虑他们的决定。所以，当有人说“我已经决定了”时，他们真正想表达的是，“我无法想象从现在到选举日之间会出现什么信息，能让我改变目前的倾向”。所以这里真正的问题是，他们想象得现实吗？我的猜测是，答案是大多数人都无法做到，因为我们不可能预知《纽约时报》上周会公布唐纳德·特朗普的纳税申报表。我们也不可能知道从现在到选举日之间无疑还会发生的各种其他事情。所以我们真正想做的是告诉人们，好吧，你现在还不知道，但这些就是从现在到选举日之间将会发生的事情。
For example, there's going to be a debate. During the debate, there's going to be lots of yelling between the candidates. They're going to be interrupting each other and so on. The viewership was not terribly high for that debate, but the news coverage of it has been substantial. And that's just one example of something that I think, you know, most people would have said we've never seen this at this level in presidential debates before. And so people guessing about are the debates going to change my mind? Well, they're thinking the debates are normal debates the way we're used to. So given that people can't know all the events that are going to unfold, we really can't expect them to guess whether they're going to change their minds.
例如，将会有一场辩论。在辩论期间，候选人之间会有很多大喊大叫。他们会互相打断等等。那场辩论的收视率并不算特别高，但新闻报道却非常多。这只是一个例子，我认为大多数人会说，我们以前在总统辩论中从未见过这种程度的混乱。所以人们猜测“辩论会改变我的想法吗？”时，他们认为辩论是那种我们习惯的正常辩论。因此，鉴于人们无法预知所有即将展开的事件，我们真的不能指望他们能猜出自己是否会改变主意。
And if you'll allow me, this is a wonderful moment to mention other landmark research and psychology done especially by Tim Wilson at the University of Virginia and Dick Nisbet from the University of Michigan back in the 70s, actually. pulling together a huge literature in psychology showing that when you ask people questions like that, how do you make decisions? Why did you decide to buy this car instead of that car? Why did you marry this person instead of somebody else? That in general, we don't have access to the working of our brains enough to be able to accurately describe the answers to those questions. And in fact, instead, what we do is we make up stories. We say, well, why would somebody marry a person like that? I guess here's a good reason. And so in this case, asking people to guess will information that they can't even anticipate change their minds is asking them what I call an Isbitt Wilson style introspective question that we're actually not prepared to answer. So forgive me for saying the premise of your question is exactly right.
如果允许我补充一点，这是一个绝佳的机会来提及心理学中其他里程碑式的研究，特别是弗吉尼亚大学的蒂姆·威尔逊和密歇根大学的迪克·尼斯贝特在70年代所做的研究。他们汇总了大量的心理学文献，表明当你问人们类似的问题时，比如“你是如何做决定的？”“你为什么决定买这辆车而不是那辆车？”“你为什么选择和这个人结婚而不是别人？”，总的来说，我们并没有足够的渠道去了解大脑的运作机制，从而无法准确描述这些问题的答案。事实上，我们所做的是编造故事。我们会说，“嗯，为什么有人会和那样的人结婚？我想这有个好理由。”所以在这个案例中，要求人们猜测他们甚至无法预见的未来信息是否会改变他们的想法，就是在问我所说的“尼斯贝特-威尔逊式”的内省问题，而我们实际上并没有准备好回答这个问题。所以请原谅我这么说，你问题的前提完全正确。
Those are the kinds of little tiny numbers of undecided voters, at least according to their own claims and surveys. But my guess is that the numbers of undecided voters are considerably higher than that, particularly because I think we know that there is plenty of ambivalence. There are people who are leaning in particular directions, but they are also on both sides of the aisle disappointed with their candidates to some degree. That there are Republicans who say in the presidential race, for example, I lean toward President Trump, but I wish he would stop doing X, Y, and Z. and others on the Democratic side who say, I've always been a Democrat, but I wish Joe would do XYZ. And so in situations like that where voters are feeling ambivalence, they are susceptible to being nudged. And so I think there is probably more nudgeability out there than those surveys might suggest. Just to change gears again, I want to talk about some of your other research because I know that in recent years, you've been.
这些就是那些未决定选民的一小部分，至少根据他们自己的说法和调查是这样。但我的猜测是，未决定选民的数量要高得多，特别是因为我认为我们知道存在大量的矛盾心理。有些人倾向于特定的方向，但他们在党派两边都对自己的候选人有一定程度的失望。例如，在总统竞选中，有共和党人说，我倾向于特朗普总统，但我希望他停止做某某事。民主党那边也有人说，我一直是个民主党人，但我希望乔能做某某事。在选民感到矛盾的情况下，他们很容易受到影响。所以我认为，比起那些调查所显示的，外面可能存在更多的“推动”空间。为了再次转换话题，我想谈谈你的一些其他研究，因为我知道近年来你一直在。
looking at climate change attitudes. And you released a survey just this summer, I believe, where you found that voters are increasingly focused on climate change and that the number of voters who say the issue is personally important to them is at an all-time high. Can you tell us more about what you found in that survey and what it means? Absolutely. Thank you for asking. My group that's based at Stanford has been doing research since the mid-90s actually tracking American public opinion on climate change. And I think we've now done about 24 national surveys over that time period, all using those scientific methods we talked about earlier, random digit dialing by human reviewers to landlines and cell phones. And when we started the
关注气候变化的态度。我相信就在今年夏天，你发布了一项调查，发现选民越来越关注气候变化，而且认为这个问题对自己个人很重要的选民人数达到了历史最高水平。你能告诉我们更多关于你在那项调查中发现了什么以及这意味着什么吗？当然。谢谢你的提问。我所在的斯坦福大学的研究小组实际上从90年代中期就开始研究追踪美国公众对气候变化的看法。我想我们在这段时间里已经做了大约24次全国性调查，全部使用了我们之前谈到的科学方法，即由人工审核员对固定电话和手机进行随机拨号。当我们开始这项
research, to be honest, I started to study this, not because I was interested in the topic, but because I was approached by the Electric Power Research Institute, asking whether I might be interested in taking a grant to do some survey studies in this area on this topic of global warming. And I said, what's that? I actually didn't know what it was. And so I agreed to do the work and got addicted to the topic because from the very start from the late 1990s when we were doing national surveys, what we found was that huge majorities of Americans at that point were better informed about the issue than I was and actually believe the earth had been warming over the last hundred years, that it's been caused importantly by human activity, that it's a threat and that it
研究时，老实说，我开始研究这个课题并不是因为我对它感兴趣，而是因为电力研究所（Electric Power Research Institute）找到我，问我是否有兴趣接受一笔拨款，在这个领域就全球变暖这个话题进行一些调查研究。我说，那是什么？我其实不知道那是什么。所以我同意做这项工作，并对这个话题上瘾了，因为从一开始，从90年代末我们进行全国调查时，我们发现当时绝大多数美国人对这个问题的了解比我还要多，而且实际上相信地球在过去一百年里一直在变暖，这是由人类活动造成的，这是一个威胁，而且它
should be dealt with by government. And so that finding of a large and sometimes huge majorities expressing those points of view were unusual back then in American politics, and they're even more unusual in the context of our image of the country as being so polarized. And that just this became very interesting to me. And what I can tell you that we found over the intervening 20 years since those first surveys was amazing stability of these opinions, that Hurricane Katrina happened and Hurricane Sandy happened. And Al Gore's two movies came out. And wildfires were devastating in parts of the country. And so on. Lots of events happened of extreme weather. hundreds of millions of dollars spent on advertising to try to convince Americans they should be
应该由政府来处理。因此，当时在美国政治中，这种表达这些观点的巨大甚至有时是压倒性的多数群体是不寻常的，而在我们国家形象如此两极分化的背景下，它们就更不寻常了。这对我来说变得非常有趣。我可以告诉你，在最初那些调查之后的20年里，我们发现这些观点有着惊人的稳定性，尽管卡特里娜飓风发生了，桑迪飓风也发生了。阿尔·戈尔的两部电影上映了。全国部分地区发生了毁灭性的野火。等等。发生了许多极端天气事件。花费了数亿美元进行广告宣传，试图说服美国人他们应该
concerned about this issue. And those huge majorities have remained remarkably stable. And yet, when we were gearing up for our survey now in 2020, we actually stretched out the interviewing period for 80 days during the COVID crisis, because what we wanted to see was, first of all, were opinions any different now than they had been before? But as the crisis, evolved, what would we see in perhaps changes in people's opinions? And the reason this is an interesting hypothesis is because of Abraham Maslow's notion that many will remember from introductory psychology class, being his hierarchy of needs. And what Maslow proposed quite reasonably is kind of a, you can think of a pyramid shape, where at the bottom are the most
关注这个问题。而那些巨大的多数群体仍然保持着惊人的稳定。然而，当我们准备在2020年进行调查时，我们实际上在新冠疫情期间延长了80天的采访期，因为我们想看看，首先，现在的观点与之前相比是否有任何不同？但随着危机的演变，我们可能会看到人们观点上的变化吗？这个有趣的假设背后的原因是亚伯拉罕·马斯洛（Abraham Maslow）的概念，许多人会从心理学入门课中记得，即他的需求层次理论。马斯洛相当合理地提出了一种你可以想象成金字塔形状的结构，最底层是
important needs that we all have to satisfy first in order to get through the day. So we need to have a place of shelter and safety. We need to have food to eat. And so those very basic needs of safety and security, Maslow said, need to get satisfied before any individual has the luxury of worrying about higher order need satisfaction. And so, for example, higher order need might be making meaningful friendships with other people. And another one might be promoting the environment, protecting the environment and so on. That worrying about the extinction of a butterfly species halfway around the world is something that is what economists might call a luxury good, something that you can only afford if the basics of your life are taken care of.
我们为了度过每一天首先必须满足的最重要的需求。所以我们需要有住所和安全。我们需要有食物吃。马斯洛说，这些非常基本的安全和保障需求，在任何个人有余力去担心更高层次的需求满足之前，都需要得到满足。例如，更高层次的需求可能是与他人建立有意义的友谊。另一个可能是促进环境，保护环境等等。担心世界另一端某种蝴蝶物种的灭绝，是经济学家所说的奢侈品，只有在你的基本生活得到保障的情况下，你才能负担得起的东西。
And that's a hypothesis that a number of scholars have taken seriously and some have published papers saying this is true and in particular saying that there's a tension between public support for environmental protection and public concern about the economy, as if there is an inevitable trade-off there. Either you attach importance to the economy thriving or you attach importance to the environment, but you can't do both. And so if that hypothesis is right, this was this year of 2020, as horrible as that has been in terms of the health crisis and the economic crisis, it does offer us as researchers an opportunity to test this notion. It's really what you can think of as an interrupted time series design, whereby no fault of our own as the researchers, we're handed
这是一个许多学者认真对待的假设，有些人发表论文说这是真的，特别是说公众对环境保护的支持与公众对经济的担忧之间存在紧张关系，好像两者之间存在不可避免的权衡。你要么重视经济繁荣，要么重视环境，但你不能两者兼顾。所以如果这个假设是正确的，那么2020年这一年，尽管在健康危机和经济危机方面非常糟糕，但它确实为我们研究人员提供了一个检验这一概念的机会。这实际上可以被认为是一种中断时间序列设计，因为我们研究人员并非出于自身过错，而是被赋予了
this opportunity to compare measurements of climate change opinions before the crisis to those during and after a crisis. And I thought, you know, there may be possible that Americans would say, this is really an unprecedented double whammy. I don't feel safe physically due to the virus. I don't feel safe economically due to the crash of the stock market at the beginning of the crisis and due to the surge of unemployment and the threats to so many small businesses. I got no mental resources here to worry about the environment. So it was a great shock to me when we repeated our survey in 2020
这个机会来比较危机前与危机期间及之后对气候变化观点的测量。我想，你知道，美国人可能会说，这真的是一次前所未有的双重打击。由于病毒，我在身体上感到不安全。由于危机初期股市崩盘以及失业率激增和对许多小企业的威胁，我在经济上感到不安全。我没有精神资源去担心环境问题。所以，当我们在2020年重复我们的调查时，我感到非常震惊，
and we found absolutely no evidence of Americans turning our, away from this issue, that the percentages of Americans saying today that the Earth has been warming over the last hundred years, that that warming is due to human activity, that government should work aggressively to address that in the future. We see absolutely no evidence of those numbers dropping in any meaningful way. And the headline that you mentioned a moment ago was, in fact, the headline that the New York Times chose to emphasize when they covered the our survey results in its first release. And the headline that you mentioned and that the Times picked up on initially has to do with what political scientists call the issue public. And so it turns
我们发现完全没有证据表明美国人背离了这个问题，今天说地球在过去一百年里一直在变暖、这种变暖是由于人类活动造成的、政府应该在未来积极采取行动解决这个问题的美国人比例。我们完全没有看到这些数字有任何明显的下降。你刚才提到的标题，实际上就是《纽约时报》在首次发布我们的调查结果时选择强调的标题。你提到的那个标题以及《时报》最初关注的标题，与政治学家所说的“议题公众”（issue public）有关。所以事实证明，
out that, you know, we're used to thinking in surveys about the general public in America. And you might think about the voting public in America. But what we've learned is it's also important to think about little groups of people who are passionate about particular policy issues. So there's a gun control issue public, there's an abortion issue public, and lots of issues that have been on the radar screen and in public debate for a long time are successful at attracting the passions of small fractions of Americans. These are people who wake up every morning, open their eyes, look across the pillow and say, good morning, gun control, another day, another opportunity for me to do something about you. And so they really are thinking that way. They're married to the issue. It comes about not easily because marrying an issue means making a big commitment.
你知道，我们习惯于在调查中考虑美国的普通公众。你可能会想到美国的投票公众。但我们学到的是，考虑那些对特定政策议题充满热情的小群体也很重要。所以有枪支管制议题公众，有堕胎议题公众，许多长期出现在雷达屏幕和公众辩论中的议题，都能成功吸引一小部分美国人的热情。这些人每天早上醒来，睁开眼睛，看着枕头对面说，早上好，枪支管制，又是新的一天，又是我可以为你做点什么的机会。所以他们确实是那样想的。他们与这个议题“联姻”了。这并不容易实现，因为与一个议题联姻意味着做出巨大的承诺。
That commitment tends to last a long time. And it tends to not only make folks who are passionate about an issue likely to write letters, to express their points of view to elected officials and to publications and on blogs, but to give money to lobbying groups, to attend protests, and most importantly, to vote based on the issue. They're listening very carefully to everything that gets said on this issue that they're married to. And they learn a lot. And they develop strong preferences.
这种承诺往往会持续很长时间。它不仅倾向于让那些对议题充满热情的人更有可能写信、向民选官员、出版物和博客表达他们的观点，而且还会向游说团体捐款、参加抗议活动，最重要的是，基于该议题进行投票。他们非常仔细地倾听关于他们所联姻的这个议题所说的一切。他们学到了很多。他们形成了强烈的偏好。
And they use those preferences to make voting decisions. And so just as there are issue publics for those other issues, there's a climate change issue public as well. And the big headline is that that climate change issue public has been of what I would call a typical magnitude for issue publics on many other issues. in the five to 12 percentage point range. And yet in this instance, the issue public has surged to an unprecedented level, up to 25%. This is one of the largest issue publics we have ever seen. And this is the percent of people in the country who say this issue is extremely important to me personally. And for most issues, the issue public is divided about equally between people who are sort of on the liberal side of the issue and the conservative side of the issue.
他们利用这些偏好来做出投票决定。所以，正如其他议题有议题公众一样，气候变化也有议题公众。最大的新闻是，气候变化议题公众的规模达到了我所说的其他许多议题议题公众的典型量级，即5%到12%的范围。然而在这种情况下，议题公众激增到了前所未有的水平，高达25%。这是我们见过的最大的议题公众之一。这就是全国范围内说“这个问题对我个人极其重要”的人的百分比。对于大多数议题，议题公众在某种程度上处于议题自由派和保守派之间的人数大致相等。
So, for example, about as many passionate pro-gun controllers as there are anti-gun controllers in the issue public. And what that means is it's a problem for candidates because a candidate who says, I'm four strong gun control laws, they will alienate about as many people as they woo. But on climate change, it's not like that. It's actually remarkable. This is the only issue we've ever seen where more than 90% of the passionate people are on what you might call the green side of the issue. These are people who believe that climate change has been happening is a threat and they support government action to address it. And there's a little group of them, less than 10% of them, who are passionate and skeptical. And those folks certainly make plenty of noise. They express their points of view in various different ways, but they are vastly outnumbered by the passionate green folks on climate. And what that means is that when a candidate is trying to decide what to talk about, how to message their constituents, how to present themselves at rallies, what positions to take publicly, climate change offers a wonderful opportunity because it turns out that all candidates, Republicans, Democrats, anybody else, chooses to take a green position is going to win more voters than they will lose. And because every issue public is small, the candidates can only assemble a coalition of supporters enough to win an election by pulling together a bunch of different issue publics and taking positions
例如，议题公众中热情的支持枪支管制的人数与反对枪支管制的人数大致相当。这意味着这对候选人来说是个问题，因为一个说“我支持强有力的枪支管制法律”的候选人，他们疏远的人数和他们争取到的人数差不多。但在气候变化问题上，情况并非如此。这实际上非常了不起。这是我们见过的唯一一个超过90%的热情人士站在你可能称之为“绿色”一边的议题。这些人相信气候变化一直在发生，是一个威胁，他们支持政府采取行动来解决它。其中有一小群人，不到10%，他们是热情的怀疑论者。这些人当然制造了很多噪音。他们以各种不同的方式表达他们的观点，但在气候问题上，他们的人数远远少于热情的绿色人士。这意味着当候选人试图决定谈论什么、如何向选民传达信息、如何在集会上展示自己、公开采取什么立场时，气候变化提供了一个绝佳的机会，因为事实证明，所有候选人，共和党人、民主党人，任何其他人，选择采取绿色立场都将赢得比失去更多的选民。而且因为每个议题公众都很小，候选人只能通过汇集一堆不同的议题公众并采取立场来组建一个足以赢得选举的支持者联盟，
on various issues to attract enough voters to support them. And here, what we've learned is that more than 50 million Americans, that's more than a quarter of the adults in the country, are prepared to vote based on this issue when the candidate expresses an enthusiastic green position. So for Democrats and Republicans, it's an opportunity to gain some votes by talking about it. Those are amazing numbers, and I wasn't aware that really they skewed in that direction and that in other cases candidates can cancel themselves out by taking a position. So it seemed like this would be a no-brainer. And yet, you know, we still find candidates who deny that there is, that global warming,
在各种议题上吸引足够的选民来支持他们。在这里，我们了解到，超过5000万美国人，也就是全国超过四分之一的成年人，准备在候选人表达热情的绿色立场时基于这个问题进行投票。所以对于民主党人和共和党人来说，谈论它是一个获得选票的机会。这些数字太惊人了，我之前并不知道它们真的向那个方向倾斜，而且在其他情况下，候选人可以通过采取某种立场而抵消自己的优势。所以这看起来应该是一个显而易见的选择。然而，你知道，我们仍然发现有候选人否认全球变暖、
climate change exists. That's kind of shocking. They need to read your study clearly. Well, actually, there is a backstory to that. And that is that a woman named Carl Davenport, who's a writer for the New York Times, did an investigative report some years ago to try to understand why it is that. about 60% of Democratic candidates tend to take green positions and almost no Republicans talk about climate change. And the argument that she made was from her investigative reporting
气候变化的存在。这有点令人震惊。他们显然需要阅读你的研究。嗯，实际上这背后有一个背景故事。那就是一位名叫卡尔·达文波特（Carl Davenport）的《纽约时报》记者，几年前做了一份调查报告，试图了解为什么大约60%的民主党候选人倾向于采取绿色立场，而几乎没有共和党人谈论气候变化。她提出的论点是，根据她的调查报道，
that the messages delivered to candidates and their campaign staff by fossil fuel lobbyists is, you know, we'd love to support your campaign, happy to give you money. But if you talk about climate change, we won't be doing that. So feel free to make your decisions about what you want to talk about, but we'll be happy to support you as long as you don't talk about climate change. And from the point of view of the fossil fuel industry, in light of the survey results I've told you, then, you know, that is kind of a desirable thing that best not to talk about this issue on which Americans would like to see change. And what's interesting is, you know, put yourself in the position of a candidate. And so a potential contributor to your campaign says, okay,
化石燃料游说者向候选人及其竞选团队传递的信息是，你知道，我们很乐意支持你的竞选，很高兴给你钱。但如果你谈论气候变化，我们就不会那样做了。所以请随意决定你想谈论什么，但只要你不谈论气候变化，我们就会很高兴支持你。从化石燃料行业的角度来看，鉴于我告诉你的调查结果，那么，你知道，这是一种理想的情况，最好不要谈论美国人希望看到改变的这个问题。有趣的是，你知道，把自己放在候选人的位置上。所以一个潜在的竞选捐款人说，好吧，
you got a choice here. You take my money or you talk about climate change and you think to yourself, okay, I know Krosnick's research. I know I could win some votes if I talk about climate change, but maybe if I don't talk about climate change and I take the money from this contributor, I can spend it on more television ads and I can win votes that way. So here we come full circle. Exactly. And so what they didn't do was they didn't read Lynn Vavrick's research and they didn't read Don Green's research. that would have told them, no, no, don't do that. Don't spend the money on advertising.
你这里有个选择。你要么拿我的钱，要么谈论气候变化，你心想，好吧，我知道克罗斯尼克（Krosnick）的研究。我知道如果我谈论气候变化，我可能会赢得一些选票，但也许如果我不谈论气候变化，我拿了这位捐款人的钱，我可以把它花在更多的电视广告上，我可以通过那种方式赢得选票。所以我们又回到了原点。没错。所以他们没有做的是，他们没有阅读琳恩·瓦夫里克（Lynn Vavrick）的研究，也没有阅读唐·格林（Don Green）的研究。那会告诉他们，不，不，不要那样做。不要把钱花在广告上。
Right. Take the votes. Take the votes. And so, yes, so there is indeed, thank you for appreciating the humor. Yeah, that's exactly what's going on. One last and highly unfair question. What's going to happen on November 3rd? Oh, Lord.
对。拿选票。拿选票。所以，是的，确实如此，感谢你欣赏这种幽默。是的，这正是正在发生的事情。最后一个非常不公平的问题。11月3日会发生什么？哦，天哪。
Well, you know, I certainly, I'm the last person that you should paint it when it comes to making predictions. But I'll tell you this, in my opinion. I think to answer a question like that, we have to use a series of considerations. The first one is that high-quality scientific polling has shown Joe Biden with healthy leads in many important states for him and neck-and-neck races in some other important states for him, such as Florida. And so in a sense, you know, so first of all, Biden appears to be winning. the popular vote in the country as a whole, that means nothing as far as who ends up in the White House in January. And so what really matters is the state polls. And what we need is as a country,
嗯，你知道，我当然是你在做出预测时最不应该问的人。但我会告诉你这一点，在我看来。我认为要回答这样的问题，我们必须使用一系列考量。第一个是高质量的科学民调显示，乔·拜登在许多对他重要的州拥有健康的领先优势，而在其他一些对他重要的州，如佛罗里达州，则是势均力敌的竞争。所以从某种意义上说，你知道，首先，拜登似乎正在赢得全国的普选票，但这对于谁最终在1月入主白宫毫无意义。所以真正重要的是各州的民调。我们需要的是作为一个国家，
I think, as many scientific surveys before election day as possible to create a shared understanding on a scientific basis of what will happen the next day and at least what should happen the next day or the next weeks, depending upon how long it takes to count those votes. Bearing in mind, of course, that what surveys can measure for us is what people say they plan to do or exit polls that are asking people what did they do are at best can measure what people think they did. And as you know, there are lots of reasons why a ballot can be invalidated according to the law. So on paper ballots, for example, if somebody were to check Donald Trump's name at the top of the ballot and then also write by hand Donald Trump's name on the other line at the bottom of a ballot that offers that
我认为，在选举日之前尽可能多地进行科学调查，以在科学基础上对第二天会发生什么，以及至少在第二天或接下来的几周内应该发生什么（取决于计算这些选票需要多长时间）建立共识。当然要记住，调查能为我们衡量的是人们说他们计划做什么，或者出口民调询问人们做了什么，充其量只能衡量人们认为他们做了什么。而且如你所知，根据法律，选票无效的原因有很多。例如在纸质选票上，如果有人在选票顶部勾选了唐纳德·特朗普的名字，然后又在提供该
opportunity. Instead of that candidate clearly being endorsed by that voter, that ballot is invalidated because it appears that according to the law, the person has voted for two different people. So the surveys can at best measure what people want to do or what they think they did, and there may be some slippage between that and a legitimate government count of those ballots according to legal prescriptions. But still, at the same time, you know, I think the first consideration to answer your question has to be that the polls at the moment that I have confidence in are issuing a signal that at the moment, if the election were held now, that Biden would have healthy leads in many places and would be neck and neck in other places that matter and that could
机会的选票底部的另一行亲手写下了唐纳德·特朗普的名字。该候选人不仅没有被该选民明确支持，该选票反而被作废了，因为根据法律，此人似乎投票给了两个不同的人。所以调查充其量只能衡量人们想做什么或他们认为自己做了什么，而在那与根据法律规定对这些选票进行的合法政府统计之间可能会有一些偏差。但尽管如此，你知道，我认为回答你问题的第一个考量必须是，我目前有信心的民调正在发出一个信号，即目前如果现在举行选举，拜登在许多地方将拥有健康的领先优势，而在其他重要的、可能
end up going in his direction. On the other hand, we know that, as I mentioned earlier, other, you know, unpredictable events will happen between now and election day. And they may well be significant. And I can't know what that's going to be. So that's a reason why I can't make a prediction. And lastly, as we know, in this unprecedented world that we're living in, there is apparently a strong evidence from the intelligence community that the Russians were knocking at the doors of dozens of states' election bureaus. working to try to get past blockades to access the electronic records of the votes and perhaps change them. As I understand it, the conclusion as of now is that no votes were actually changed
最终会转向他的地方将是势均力敌。另一方面，我们知道，正如我之前提到的，其他不可预测的事件会在现在到选举日之间发生。它们很可能是重大的。我无法知道那会是什么。所以这就是我无法做出预测的原因。最后，正如我们所知，在这个我们所处的前所未有的世界里，情报界显然有强有力的证据表明，俄罗斯人正在敲开数十个州选举局的大门。努力试图越过封锁以获取选票的电子记录，并可能更改它们。据我所知，目前的结论是实际上没有选票被更改
as a result of that. But there's certainly a sense in which in some communities, the ability to detect and prevent those kinds of electronic intrusions has not necessarily improved over the last four years. And so that's another element that I can't personally anticipate and that may well be consequential. Of course, remember, it need be small. It doesn't have to be a big nudge. It's just in a case where the race is close. Just a few votes can be pushed one way or another. And HBO in particular has a couple of very overwhelming documentaries for those who are interested in watching them that describe the flaws in the electronic voting techniques that are, technology that are used.
作为那次事件的结果。但肯定有一种感觉，在一些社区，检测和防止这类电子入侵的能力在过去四年里并没有必然提高。所以这是另一个我个人无法预料的因素，而且很可能是后果严重的。当然，记住，它需要很小。它不需要是一个大的推动。只是在竞争激烈的情况下。几张选票就可以被推向一个方向或另一个方向。HBO特别为那些有兴趣观看的人提供了几部非常震撼的纪录片，描述了所使用的电子投票技术中的缺陷。
And so if you're looking for something else to do tonight, go look for those documentaries, one very new and one older, that will make the hair on the back of your next stand on end. And, you know, these are all challenges for us as a country at the moment, but there are also challenges for me in trying to answer your question if we make a prediction about what's going to happen next month. So the answer is I have no prediction. We'll just have to wait.
所以如果你今晚想找点别的事做，去看看那些纪录片，一部非常新，一部较旧，会让你毛骨悚然。而且，你知道，这些都是我们作为一个国家目前面临的挑战，但如果我们要对下个月会发生什么做出预测，这也是我在试图回答你的问题时面临的挑战。所以答案是我没有预测。我们只能等着看。
Yeah, I hope we are all left standing after it's all over. Amen to that. Well, thank you so much for joining us today, Dr. Crosslink. It's been really fascinating talking with you. Well, it's a great pleasure. I thank you, and I thank the American Psychological Association for doing your work. We as psychologists toil in the fields, but it's events like this that provide us a privilege of being able to disseminate our work, and I hope that your listeners have found it valuable, and I hope we as a field of psychology continue to thrive for many years to come.
是的，我希望这一切结束后我们都能安然无恙。阿门。好吧，非常感谢你今天加入我们，克罗斯尼克博士。和你交谈真的非常引人入胜。嗯，这是我的荣幸。我感谢你，也感谢美国心理学会所做的工作。我们作为心理学家在田野里辛勤耕耘，但正是这样的活动让我们有幸能够传播我们的工作，我希望你的听众觉得它很有价值，也希望我们作为心理学领域在未来许多年里继续蓬勃发展。
I am sure they will, and we will. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.competingof Psychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening.
我相信他们会，我们也会。谢谢。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）之前的剧集。如果你有关于未来播客的评论或想法，请发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，连在一起，at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。感谢收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。